welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and that's just
been a ton of new images dropped on June
the upcoming film is due to release on
December 18th and fans of the original
1965 novel and 1984 movie have a lot of
things to look forward to throughout
this video we're going to be breaking
down the new Vanity Fair article and
giving our thoughts on how the film
looks there may be some spoilers here so
if you want to go into the movie as
blind as possible then I highly
recommend that you turn off now make
sure you subscribe to the channel to
never miss a video and please drop a
thumbs up if you enjoy the content
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our breakdown of
June ok so the first official image on
the film dropped yesterday on the 13th
of April it showcased Timothy sha'lame
is Paul our trainees and it's certainly
spiced up the internet quite a lot get
it because it because of spice now this
was exciting because not only did we get
an amazing teaser of the film but it
also highlighted that the movie will
likely not be delayed and that it will
indeed his release day in December
Paul was surrounded by ships on what
looked to be Khalid an it was extremely
dark and moody and it looks like it will
probably be the most authentic portrayal
of the book on the big screen when
discussing this
Timothy stated that the most appealing
thing about all of this is the amount of
scale detail and world building that has
gone into the film that his character is
going to be on a sort of antihero
journey it was definitely enough to whet
the appetite of diehard dune fans and I
saw a whole host of people discussing
the first look on Twitter yesterday jump
forward to today and we have a whole
host of new images that have been
showcased in a Vanity Fair article these
outstanding pieces all look like works
of art and they really bring the
universe to light Shalem a stay that the
creative team have really transformed
the vast deserts that they filmed in
into huge Goliath like landscapes
there are planets that you'd imagine
existing within our universe but not on
our earth the article goes on to discuss
just how much the locations were
transformed into the dusty dry
battleground of Arrakis this planet is
home to the galaxy's most vital resource
the mind-altering a time and space
warping spice Paul is to be a stranger
in this land who is fighting to protect
his hostile new home from the gigantic
sand worms that burrow into the land you
really get the feeling of just how
immense the scope of the movie will be
here there are a ton of images ranging
from Josh Brolin to Rebecca Ferguson and
Oscar Isaacs
I think the star-studded cast really
bring the Herbert's storyline to life
and it's clear that they are giving the
work a lot of love and attention which
it definitely deserves
we know that Ferguson is playing lady
Jessica or tradies and the article says
that these two will accompany one
another throughout the film as
companions Oscar Isaac is playing Paul's
father Duke Leto Atreides and Jason
Momoa is playing Duncan Idaho there's a
ton of things to pick out in the images
but I just love the overall scope of
them Jun is often been said to be them
vulnerable and the cast's are clearly
taking this on board with the articles
stating that it wouldn't be June if it
was easy director Dennis villian away
whose name always get wrong has stated I
would not agree to make this adaptation
of the book with one single movie the
world is too complex it's a world that
takes its power in details so from this
we can take that there are definitely
plans for a sequel and it does seem like
this movie will focus predominantly on
world-building this is a series that
takes a lot of power in its detail and
the director has said that he thinks Jun
is more relevant today than it was when
it was first created the way the planet
is changing and resources are becoming
more and more sparse it makes sense to
focus on the youth of the future that
could exist in a universe where every
day is a fight to survive chellamay has
said that he thinks Paul is struggling
to find his place and we did learn from
yesterday's information that he has a
supernatural gift that allows him to
harness and unleash energy so you can
bet that the visuals will be extremely
unique and it will be something that we
haven't really seen before we also
learned from the article that his father
Duke and mother lady Jessica have taken
the character from his lush Scandinavian
like home world to preside over the
spice extraction on Arrakis
they are then attacked by criminals and
the characters have to defend themselves
from that point onwards the director
also explained the role of Paul's mother
and said
she has sort of Jedi mind-trick powers
and could control people through her
voice she is very much someone that can
manipulate the balance and power of the
universe and because of this she's
highly sought after
however she isn't an easy person to take
down and when casting the role the
studio wanted a Warrior Priestess rather
than just a space nun lady Jessica's
Duty is to deliver a savior to the
universe and it is likely that Paul will
take up this mantle she and his father
are training him and they wish to bring
peace once more to a galaxy riddled with
war there are of course a lot of other
side characters and overall I'm blown
away by the way that the movie looks now
there have been some aspects of
controversy around the film with doctor
Lee at Cannes who is predominantly
depicted as a white man now becoming a
black woman denna stated that there were
a lack of female characters in the cast
and he wanted to write a role for a
woman he stated that kinds is supposed
to keep peace amongst the people and
that women are very good at that so it
made sense for him to change the gender
up the book does talk about a lot of
politics and it does seem like they are
aiming for that sort of direction with
this release there will of course be a
lot of cool things to look forward to
such as the Mentats which are humans
augmented with computer-like Minds
Jason Momoa and Josh Brolin are going to
be playing two of these that mentor Paul
so it does seem like there will be a
love aspects in the film going into
Paul's character
overall Jun is a really difficult book
to adapt but I'm really excited by what
we've seen so far it seemed to be
completely nailing the tone and I'm just
very hype for the end result have seen a
lot of people a bit weary with how dark
and grim the film looks wanna see I
quite like that another things like
Blade Runner 2049 which is an excellent
film I know they don't tend to do well
at the box office but I'm glad that
they're going all out with it and
actually taking risks and making plays
that aren't necessarily the safe option
the fact that the movie is trending on
Twitter right now does show that there
is a lot of hype surrounding it and if
it's good I can really see it taking off
time will tell but for now I'm really
excited by this first look now obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
images so comment below and let me know
you enjoy this video then please give it
a thumbs up and make sure you check out
our breakdown of Westworld season 3
which is going to be linked at the
and we go over everything you need to
know about it so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
you want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below
we massively appreciate you and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at definition
whitey or click the discord link in the
description below every month we give
away free movies to people our subscribe
to the channel and this month you can
win the Star Wars Skywalker saga box set
and all you have to do is comment on a
video and make sure you so good no
fication Zahn more videos who comment on
the more you have a chance of winning so
make sure you get involved the winners
gonna be chosen at random tomorrow on
the 15th of April so best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe huge thank you
for taking the time to watch this I've
been definition you've been the best not
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]